all right Steve is whether Steve is in
Salt Lake City hi Steve welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for
taking my call I've been listening for
years and never thought I'd be calling
in to ask your advice but I find myself
in some uncharted territory here okay oh
my help I'm trying to bail out a
relative in another state who's done
something incredibly stupid and
irresponsible
she took her only possession a
automobile that she owns and has clear
title to that we actually paid for in
2011 last March she took it to a title
loan shark company to get a $3,000 cash
loan against the title at 118 percent
interest um she is an unemployed single
mother of two school-aged children her
only source of income is medi-cal
disability payments welfare checks food
stamps and lives in section 8 housing
and since March of last year she has
paid in 3000 dollars of monthly payments
actually semi-of monthly payments of
hundred and fifty dollars but between
missing payments and payment partial
payments there are hundreds and hundreds
of dollars of late fees so as of this
weekend there was a $3,200 plus I'm
sorry $3,500 pay off balance on this
three thousand dollar loan I called over
the weekend and spoke to their weekend
manager trying to see if I could
negotiate something I could come up with
$2,500 cash right away if they would
clear the loan and release the title
with all the appropriate things that I
hear you say you must get everything in
writing
they in turn said well we'll have to
turn it over to our collections
department and I'll get back to you
Monday or Tuesday I haven't heard from
them yet and I'm just trying to figure
out how I could Girt myself for battle
using the adam2 Dave Ramsey get in your
face techniques if it's even reasonable
to do so I don't think you got many
cards are holding in this deck this is
known as a bluff because they're pretty
much just going to take her car well
especially considering that the KBB
trade imbalances of around 7,000 $190 so
if I'm in their shoes I don't know why
I'd settle okay
I don't know that you're going to get a
settlement I mean that's part of the
deal is you have to go anytime you're
negotiating you have to gather up
information put the other guy's shoes on
for a minute and figure out why he would
work with you that's not an unsecured
debt where they have no way of
collecting it from a broke lady they
they are hoping she doesn't pay it is
their business model that they take the
$7,000 car for $3,000 Oh
after by the way she's already paid them
three thousand dollars what a bargain
for them and so this is why I titled
pompon is as you said a stupid thing to
do in a complete ripoff and it screws
people it's a horrid horrid product
scummy scummy scummy so so I yeah you're
probably going to pay them every dime to
get this title now the man asked you
this then what happens because I don't
hear anything in this lady's story that
makes me think she's not going to turn
around title pawn it again this time
next year well we thought that we could
actually take position of the title but
apparently that's not good enough
because they can call and have skipped
keep the copy of it and once they
register the title by having a piece of
paper in my hand doesn't do any good so
you're absolutely right there's nothing
good well she could transfer title to
you you could become the owner of the
car then she couldn't do anything with
it yes and then she's driving your car
in which case if she wrecks it you get
sued by the way how fine is that yeah so
I'm thinking that's probably not worth
it either
you know what I want to do is I really
look at these things holistically and I
say gosh I want to help her but I also
want to be sure I'm not giving a drunk a
drink what else can we do in her life to
get her life moving because in my mind I
don't know about it in her mind but in
my mind her life sucks well there's
definitely an attitude problem a sense
of entitlement and well I used to want
to deal with it all go off to the
emergency room and be treated for
anxiety again
no you're right though so so well how is
this how is this not a short-term
solution for this particular financial
situation yeah I really want to help her
and I don't mind if you choose to help
her I mean you can do it if you want - I
have a feeling $3,000 in you change your
life probably I might know but uh but
but if you give this $3,000 you just got
to know it sounds like there's a really
good opportunity that that it's all
going to be undone later so you need to
have managed your own expectations that
this is not going to change your life
Andrea you know so you're you're
probably just throwing this money out
the window it's okay to do that
sometimes and you just say well it's an
act of mercy I'm just going to try to be
nice and who knows sometimes something
like that flips a switch but I I
generally am a lot more hardcore when
I'm assisting someone and making sure
that I'm getting some life change out of
the deal for their benefit otherwise I
might let them just lay in their Pig mud
in the pigsty that they're laying in and
I and it's not cause that and that
sounds so harsh and so mean but as you
and I have said and discuss this you
keep telling me over her she don't care
she likes the smell of the mud and you
know it's her it's her modus operandi
and so I mean why would I want to take a
pig out of mud they love the mud let him
stay um so I just thought that's that's
awful I mean I don't know it's hard
I appreciate your sweetheart your
compassion towards her Steven and I
don't mind you doing it I'm not telling
you don't do it don't do it but you just
got to brace yourself for the idea of
this car may be right back at that same
exact title palm place in four months
she may put it right back over there and
I really would I would try to do
something to bring her healing of her
spirit about because she's someone who's
hopeless and broken and doesn't believe
she can win him or she feels stuck and
then they what happens is people then
retreat into this entitlement mentality
and ironically she completely lives on
entitlements is what you describe so you
and I take care of her already
it's called taxpayer benefits so hard
decisions just have so much to do with
your future they have so much to do with
whether you win or not and you get to
make better decisions you have that as
an option helps this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you